هذا هو وجه الشجاعة
لقاء أناستازيا البالغة من العمر 15 عامًا ،
وهي مراهقة شجاعة ومتحدية
تتعافى الآن من إصاباتها في السد.
ساعد
رجلين مصابين في الوصول إلى المستشفى
، كانت هناك حاجة ماسة للمساعدة حتى
لا تفقد الكثير من الدم ، كما تقول ،
حملت مفاتيح السيارة
واضطررت للجلوس خلف عجلة القيادة ، وتقول
إنهم شقوا طريقهم عبر الجسر في
أمس الحاجة إلى  عند الوصول إلى مستشفى في
بهرموت ،
لدينا جسر وكان لدينا عقول هناك
، ولم يكن هناك طريقة للوصول إلى نمط رقعة الشطرنج ،
لكنني نجحت بطريقة
ما ، وهناك بعد ذلك
جثة امرأة تقول إن
الأسوأ هو أن يأتي انفجار  أشعلت نيران مدفع رشاش
السيارة التي
كنت
أقودها ثم أطلق الروس النار علينا عندما
بدأوا في إطلاق النار توقفت السيارة
ثم شغلت السيارة مرة أخرى وواصلت القيادة
رغم أنها كانت مصابة ونزيف.
كان الوقت ينفد
، توقفت السيارة بسبب إطلاق رصاصة على بطارية
من
قبل الجنود الأوكرانيين
لإنقاذ أناستازيا وركابها
الآن يتعافون جميعًا بفضل
شجاعة السائق الصغير جدًا
عيسى سواريز سي إن ليفي أوكرانيا